there's a thing i had kind of this
fictional thing i'd created i'd watched
lots of disaster films i'd read lots of
books about it and
fictional fictional books about
pandemics and suddenly seeing it play
out in the real world was horrible
imagine the pandemic was a video game
well three years ago that's all it was i
sat down with james vaughan the man
behind plague inc which successfully
predicted much of the virus to find out
how he's adapted to the reality of covet
19.
[Music]
i'm the creator of this game called
plaguing which sets to
simulate how an infectious disease would
spread around the world
time 2104
27 year old female infected with unknown
pathogen
blood analysis
indicates
virus you launched then in 2012 yeah and
very rapidly it seems from the outside
it was quite successful and it was
popular in app stores and within a few
hours it made its development costs back
i spent two and a half grand making it
which at the time felt like a serious
investment that was that was my ability
my house deposit going down the drain
but it made that money back within a
couple of hours
it was a viral success story it only did
well because people were playing it
160 million people have downloaded
james's game in the past decade it now
averages 40 to 50 000 new players every
single day
you've got the game open yes how how
does it start what do i do various
modifiers in the game you choose your
difficulty you can choose how often
people wash their hands how hard doctors
work as as the as the game progresses
we'll see these red dots down in down in
china over here begin to slowly spread
around the place now at the moment
very very basic still but that will
begin to grow
i suppose then fast forward to
early last year
where you know you've been developing
this game where the intention is to sort
of wipe out the global population then
all of a sudden there is a virus that is
kind of accelerating towards that as
well
can you take me back to the moment where
you found out about the virus and that
it was really starting to make headlines
so
it was a very very difficult time for us
actually i i can i can i think i i can
remember first seeing the reports um
coming out of china it didn't
immediately set off huge alarm bells
with me because one thing i've learned
during the development and playing is
that there's always unknown scary
disease outbreaks popping up around the
place so it popped up on the radar and
then i think it was
mid-january end of january when i
started getting
thinking oh blimey what's
what's going on here like it was seeing
the the parallels with my game playing
out in the real world that was a
horrible experience was the thing i had
kind of this fictional thing i'd created
i'd watched lots of disaster films i'd
read lots of books about it and
fictional fictional books about
pandemics and suddenly seeing it play
out in the real world it was horrible
in response to the covert outbreak the
plague inc team started out in early
2020 by donating money to help tackle
the pandemic but then another idea came
up
so when we were looking to give money to
um which i and sepi one of the things
they kept on saying was well it's great
that you're donating money have you
thought about doing a version of plague
where you turn it on its head and you're
actually stopping a disease because
plaguing on its own helps inform people
but imagine how good it would be if
people could be playing around with
lockdowns and mask wearing and when to
start developing a vaccine the more
these conversations happened i thought
well you know what yes right we should
do it
james's team then came up with a new
iteration of their game with the help of
world health organization experts
they named it plagueinc the cure
are there things that um you know you
you sit there as an outsider and looking
at some of the things that it that
you've built into your models gone
actually there might have been better
tech solutions for this sort of thing
oh blimey um
i think for me the the biggest thing has
been a failure to combat misinformation
sooner it's being combated
averagely okay now but they could have
been far more done on that sooner and
before it had taken root as much and i
think the whole concept of the
misinformation um in sort of exploiting
the the channels that various tech
companies have built is a
huge problem for a with the pandemic and
we're still and we're still seeing this
reverberate through at the moment maybe
more so now than in the early days of
the pandemic but even beyond the
pandemic as well it's it's that that for
me is the big thing which i think tech
companies should be doing more to combat
if you're playing the cure
what would be that the step you would be
taking right now
i think for me it's about vaccine
distribution everywhere and this is one
of the reasons why we wanted to support
sepi their their mission is about
getting vaccines they work with gavi and
others to get vaccines all around the
world like you you've got all these pots
of non-vaccinated places
wonderful breeding grounds for for so in
the game we make it easy we say once
you've got the vaccine it goes to
everybody democratically fairly we're
not we're not seeing that here so get
the vaccines out to people as fast as
possible but it's actually not even
about that anymore now it's about
education and information it comes back
to the misinformation i said that is our
biggest threat
you